[موسيقى]
حياكم الله قضت محكمه التركيه بسجن رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول المعارض والذي يحظى بشعبيه
واسعه اكرم امام اوغلو عامين وسبعه اشهر
من ممارسه العمل السياسي وذلك بسبب اهانه
مسؤولينا ووصفهم بالاغنيه الحكم قد يقود
الى فرض حظر سياسي على رئيس البلديه الى
عيادته المحكمه العليا
مع اقتراب موعد الانتخابات المزرعه عقدها
في تركيا في يونيو العام المقبل بدوره قال
اكرم امام اوغلو في اول تعليق على قرار
المحكمه انه لا يمكن لاحد اخذ السلطه التي
يتم منحها من قبل الناخبين مضيفا ان الحكم
غير قانوني ويعكس الاوضاع الحاليه في
تركيا امام محاميه فكد بانه سيستاذن في
الحكم وهو ما يعني ان اكرم امام اوغلو
سيبقى في منصبه رئيسا للبلديه لكنه باتا
مستبعدا من الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرره
العام المقبل
وهي لا تحترم القانون ولا الاخلاق كما
حاولت السلطه في تركيا تعطيل عمل بلديه
اسطنبول بعد خساره الانتخابات واريد ان
اشير الى انه تم تغيير القاضي الذي كان
موكلا بقضيته لانهم حسوا بانه لن يصدر
حكما كما يرغبون تركيا تقف على مفترق طرق
بين من يقبل بالسياده الوطنيه دون قيد او
شرط وبين من لديهم حساسيه من السياده
الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
معنى من انقرا المحلل السياسي بركات عقار
وايضا من اسطنبول لا ينضم الينا الدكتور
بكير اتجان مدير معهد اسطنبول اهلا بكما
ليبدا اولا مع السيد بركات هل استطاع
اردوغان عبر هذا الحكم القضائي من ان
يتخلص من اقوى خصومه في الانتخابات
المقبله
مساء الخير اولا مساء النور لا شك هو
الهدف من هذه الحكم بالحقيقه هذا الامر
يعني التخلص واذا صح التعبير التنظيف
الطريق امامي لكن اذا بدنا ننظر بشكل عام
للصوره الكامله بالحقيقه عمل جزء اكبر غلط
في هذه
التسييس القضاء واتخاذ هذه القرار لانه
القرار يعني الان كل المتابعين يعني في
تركيا والخارج لا احد يسمع
تصريحا واحد بانه والله قرار فعلا قضايا
حقوقي لا علاقه للسلطه به
وين الاعتراض اين الاعتراض يعني هذا حكم
قضائي كيف كيف يكون مسيسا
عزيز الكريم بانه في تركيا القضاء مسيس
اصبح وهذه الامر ليس اول حادثه في تركيا
سبق
وعزل ما يقارب فوق الستين رئيس بلديه
منتخب بين من الشعب في جنوب شرق تركيا هذا
معروفه
والحقيقه من بدايه فوز همم
بلديه رئيس اسطنبول امامه اوغلو لم تهضم
هذه الهزيمه من قبل السلطه من قبل الحزب
العدالي لحتى الان وليس في في اسطنبول فقط
بعشر مدن اخرى كبرى ودائما كان همم
العثرات امامهم والفرد عليهم قرارات جديده
والتحرش بكل قراراتهم حتى
في عندما يحاول ان يستقرضوا بعد همم
الامور الماليه ايضا لا لم تم الموافقه
عليها وتكون مقاطعه تماما لذلك الامر هو
سياسي تمبحت يعني لا علاقه له في الحقوق
سيد همم الدكتور بكير اتجان سيد بركات
يقول بان هذا الحكم مسيس وبالتالي ماذا
ترد على ماذا على ما قال
هل توافق مساء الخير تحياتي لكم مساء
النور اولا لابد الاشاره الى بعض النقاط
المهمه همم اولا هذه همم انقلاب سياسي
بامتياز مدبره من طرف الولايات المتحده
والدول الاوروبيه
بالتعاون مع المعارضه التركيه في داخل
تركيا
على على على
داخل حزب الشعب الجمهوري على على كرستار
اوغلو على كريستالو لماذا لماذا
اولا جميع استطلاعات الراي العام في
الفتره الاخيره كانت تعطي بالنسبه للمرشحه
التي سوف يكونون ضد اردوغان ثلاث مرشحين
من الاحزاب المعارضه وعلى راسهم امام مغلق
ومن ثم قد اشتروا ومن ثم منصوره واش يعني
رئيس بلديه انقره ورئيس بلديه اسطنبول
ورئيس حزب همم الشعب الجمهوري لكن همم
معظم استطلاقات الراي العام وخاصه في
الفتره الاخيره اصبح الذي همم يعني كان
رئيسا لرئيس بلديه اسطنبول امامه همم
المرتبه الثالثه حسب الاستطلاعات الراي
العام ولذلك خرج همم حزب رئيس الحزب الشعب
الجمهوري كان اصداره له والدعب انه
والمرشح الاول لماذا وفي الفتره الاخيره
استطلاط الراي العام كانت تعطي لرئيس
بلديه انقره الاول الثاني والثالث همم
فلذلك حصل انقلاب همم محاوله كتابيه
سياسيه لان القرار الحكم لن يصدر بعد
هذا طلب من المدعي العام في حال وافقت
محكمه الاستئناف
يعترض عليها وتذهب الى محكمه التمييز
ويعترض عليها واذا ااا لن تقبل الاعتراض
تكون هذه القرارات يعني اكيده ولكن الى
الان ليست اكيده ثانيا اعطت المجال
همم امام اغلبي ان يترشح هو يكون المرشح
الاول لماذا لان الشعب الذي معظمه وخاصه
في الاناضول لا يعرف امامه وخاصه في
الفتره الاخيره الاساءه التي جاءت على
لسان بعض الناس وخاصه استغلاله ل منصبه ضد
مصلحه الشعب التركي حيث كان هناك الثلوج
وهو ياكل ويتعشى مع هو كان انتخي مالي
لاعطي لاعطي سيد بركات المجال يرد على كل
كل ذلك دكتور دكتور اذا سمحت ليعطيه السيد
بركات يرد على كل ذلك ماذا ترد سيد بركات
على كل ما قاله هذا هذه عمليه تصفيه
داخليه
بحترم انا وجهه نظر
اي انسان لكن نحن يجب ان نطلع الى النتائج
والى الاجراءات هذه السلطه الان الحاليه
في مساله ال ال الحقوق في مساله العداله
في مساله التساوي في حقوق الحريات للاسف
طيب ماذا تفعل المعارضه
الحكم طيب
هذا بالحق انا بالحقيقه بالحقيقه لا اعرف
يعني شو بيعمل وهل سيكون مرشح ام لا يعني
هذا انا بهمني الان الايراد الشعبي في
تركيا وما وصلت اليها من من اعتراضات على
هذه السياسات القائمه للسلطان يعني بكل
المجالات للاسف شديد الحذر مستمر بكل
المجالات اتصوروا يعني الان ااه في الامس
كان في اضراب عامله احد النقابات منع تم
الحذر عليه بانه الطلاب محظور ان يقوموا
باي عمل الاتحاد الاتحاد المعلبين كان في
يوم السبت عندهم لقاء
واسعارها
الدوله كما قال امام
هل توافق ذلك بان الدوله تنقلب على
القانون هذه الدوله لا كما قال لا اوافق
لا اوافق طبعا لا اوافق ذلك لكن الان
اصبحت الدوله
بدوله الحزب الواحد للاسف الشديد وهو
الحزب الواحد هو يقر بكل ما يلزم وبكل ما
يعني الكلمه في المجتمع هذه المشكله
الكبيره يعني لو هذه اصبحت هزي هزي ارضيه
مجتمعيه فعلا الان في اسطنبول وهذه لم
تبقى في حدود اسطنبول انا بتقديري ستنتشر
بكل تركيا ضد حزب العداله حزب العداله ما
كان بحاجه لهذه التسييس ولهذه القرار
بالحقيقه دكتور اخر جمله يعني الان كثيرين
من قيادات حزب العداله نقدوا نقدا شديدا
هذه القرار واعتبروه قرار سياسي
كيف ترى ذلك كل ما تفضل به السيد بركات هل
توافق بين ان الدوله تريد ان تتفرد بالحكم
وبالتالي تخصي معارضينها
لا سيدي هذه اقصاء
للاردوغان اقصاء لحزب
العداله والتنميه لماذا لان معروف بتركيا
بان هذا القرار لو طبقا من اليوم تحتاج
الى سنه ونصف تطبيقها بمعنى اخر ال ااه
امامه اذا اراد يستطيع ان يترشح واذا نجح
في الانتخابات لان الانتخابات ماكسيمام بس
ست شهور هناك حصانه والحصانه له بمعنى غير
قابل للتطبيق هذه القرارات في الايام
القادمه اذا نجح طبيعي لرئاسه الجمهوريه
ثانيا
الشعب التركي دائما يميل الى المظلومين
هذا ما حصل قبل السنين بالنسبه لاردوغان
عندما سجن وعندما قرا شعرا ولكن هنا السجن
المطلوب لامام اغلوب بانه احتقار
للجنه الانتخابات وليس قراءه يعني في فرق
كبير بين ما فعله اردوغان وسجن على سريري
وهنا ثانيا هذه الفتره الزمنيه لا يوجد
فيها سجن ايضا يعني سنتين وسبعه شهور 15
يمنع من الانتخابات ان يبتعد عن السياسه
سنتين ونصف ولكن هذه عندما يعني بعد سنه
ونصف تقرر المحاكم القرار النهائي الى
الان غير معروف لا يوجد شيء ثالثا اعطى
شهره الامام
انتخابيه قبل الانتخابات دول العالم
يعطيه بانه يستطيع النجاح ضد اردوغان طيب
عفوا يعني هذه تقصد انه هو استغلها
انتخابيا كدعايه اعلاميه قبل الانتخابات
نعم سوف يستغلها انتخابايا ولكن هذا
الاستغلال سوف تكون ضد اردوغان وضد رئيس
الحزب همم الشعبي الجمهوري الذي كان مرشح
القوي الى الان سيد بركات هذه استغلال
انتخابيه يعني الى الان لم يحدث شيء سيد
بركات قار الى الان لم يحدث شيء وبالتالي
هو استغلال انتخاب المعركه انتخابيه اذا
كان
اذا كان استغلال انتخابي عزيزي الكريم
بانه بيد من السلطه الان بانه القصر هو
يحدد وهو يقرر
لا ما بعد الانتخابات
نعم ممكن تطول ممكن تطول لكن بالحقيقه
الامر ليس ك- كذلك يعني الان هذه القرار
هو انا بتقديري غلطه كبيره بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
طيب تفضل دكتور
هناك هناك اقتراح او طلب من
البرلمانيين حزب العداله والتنميه منذ
2019 بان اي انسان سياسي ياخذ حكم لا لا
تستطيع القوانين التركيه ان تمنعه من
المشاركه في السياسه كمرشح او كعضو او ما
يريد
العداله والتنميه بمعنى اخر اامامه يترشح
مهما كانت النتائج ان كانت يعني له صالحه
او ضده نقطه لان هذه مهمه جدا بمعنى اخر
هذه اذا مصطنعه من طرف من اطراف
الجمهوريه التركيه وعلى راسها رئيس
الجمهوريه اردوغان لانهم يعني
السيد بركات يقول ان السلطه بيبدا العداله
والتنميه لا يكون الحظ كما يملكها امام
مغلق يا دكتور السلطه بيد العداله
والتنميه وليست بيد المعارضه
سيد العزيز هناك قوانين اقول الانتخابات
سوف تكون اقل من ست شهور وهذا يعني
القوانين غير ممكن تطبيقها خلال سته اشهر
ثانيا هذا كان من المقرر يترشح حزب الشعب
الرئيس الحزب الشعبي الجوري والذي لا
يمتلك الى الان خسر 11 مره في الانتقالات
ولكن امام مغلق مدعوم داخليا وخارجيا من
الولايات المتحده ومن دول الاوروبيه الذي
كان دكتور شكرا
انقلاب سياسي بامتياز باختصار بقي عندي
دقيقه تفضل
يعني بس سؤال يعني متى السلطه الان حزب
العداله والتنميه هي ضد امريكا يعني
بالحقيقه هذا كلام غير مضبوط وغير حقيقي
بانه هذه العمليه عمليه محاوله انقلاب الى
اخر هذا طيب
يقول انه اعضاء البرلمان في حزب العداله
والتنميه قدمه على قانون حتى لا يحرم
سياسي في حاله ادانته من خوض الانتخابات
يا عزيزي تحرم تحرم السياسيين بالسجن هناك
العشرات الالاف الناس في السجن تحرم بكذلك
الامر وتحرم الان الاقاله الرؤساء
البلديات اكثر من 60 بلديه منتخب الان
بالسجون يعني كيف بانهم ضد السجون هذا غير
صحيح بالحقيقه لذلك انا بقول اخر شيء بانه
حزب العداله منذ 20 سنه وهو يحكم هذه
البلد كيف ممكن بانه حاكم او اي هيئات
تتجرا وتاخذ قرار ضده هذه مستحيل مستحيل
بين كما جبي تقرير الكم بالبدايه بانه
حاكم مش كانوا مطمئنين لقراره ضد امام
اوغلو اجي اقاله وارسلوه ابعدوه لمدينه
اخرى لذلك الان المحاكم للاسف الشديد لن
تتخذ اي قرار
المعارضين او على الاقل همم
تدعمهم شكرا جزيلا
للمحلل السياسي بركات جار وايضا للدكتور
بكير اتجان مدير معهد اسطنبول للفكر كنتم
معنا من انقروا اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لكم